hola rodrigo bueno justamente este es
uno de los puntos por los cuales está
siendo tan criticado internacionalmente
el concepto de democracia y es que esta
cruzada de nadie bukele en contra de eso
de las pandillas tiene un eco una
resonancia una aprobación de parte del
congreso de una manera irrestricta la
respuesta es no porque el congreso solo
podría extender el estado de excepción
es el motivo por el cual fue decretado
inicialmente
se estuviera replicando es decir que si
los más de 80 asesinatos que se
registraron un fin de semana en marzo de
este año se estuvieran replicando a lo
largo de los meses bien podría el
congreso extender el estado de excepción
pero no lo está haciendo lo está
haciendo bajo la justificación abro
comillas hasta encarcelar a todos los
terroristas de manera tal que el
congreso la asamblea con 67 votos a
favor 15 en contra 0 abstenciones
[Música]
un quinto mes en el estado de excepción
que es la fecha de aproximadamente
así que se espera llegar a la cifra de
son los pandilleros que tienen
registrado el gobierno dibujen en sus
estadísticas y andrés a medida que
avanza este estado de excepción y las
detenciones como bien has explicado
organismos de derechos humanos ahora
están recepcionando centenares de
detenciones arbitrarias de personas que
serían inocentes que actualización hay
al respecto
bueno ayer precisamente se pudo ver en
las calles de san salvador un grupo de
más de 200 familias dirigiéndose
marchándose marchando hacia la casa
presidencial de nadie bukele para
exigirle la liberación de sus parientes
que presuntamente fueron capturados
arrestados sin justa causa y además de
organizaciones de derechos humanos
presentaron un informe muy detallado
entre el grupo de trabajo de detenciones
arbitrarias de las naciones unidas donde
se detalla las represiones y las
violaciones a los derechos humanos que
se estarían cometiendo en el salvador en
estos meses de estado de excepción y es
que se han recepcionado más de 2.200
denuncias de personas que habrían sido
capturadas de una manera ilegal es decir
uno sin los requisitos para llevar a
cabo esta captura y dos sin las
evidencias sin las pruebas prácticas de
la comisión de los delitos de manera que
con este informe se espera que el grupo
de trabajo detenciones arbitrarias de la
onu pueda realizar una visita oficial a
el salvador y pedirle y el que rinda
cuentas para que no se estén realizando
más violaciones de derechos humanos